hello everyone are we getting close to
time to get started no one else coming
in so I guess we might as well I got a
ton of stuff to talk cover so did the
sooner we can get started the better is
everybody having a good day
even though it's early in the morning oh
let's see let me try that everybody
having a good day I love this so much
one of my last presentations was in
Belgium you go in and you say everybody
having a good day
silence you cracked the best joke you
know and it's complete silence so I love
the fact that there's some feedback
that's awesome so it's topic of today is
authentication and a little bit of
authorization in asp.net Core 2 it's
quite an important part that it is
actually 2.0 or 2.1 they rewrote the
whole thing from 1 to 2 and I will be
covering what's in 2 which is completely
different from one so my name is Chris
Klug I work at the company in Stockholm
called captain 34 where my official
title is ninja which basically means
nothing because everyone is a ninja or
company but I traveled the world
speaking at conferences sharing
knowledge as much as I can and once in a
while I do touch a keyboard and write
code for real for clients it's been a
while now though and for some reason
I've got stuck with doing a lot of what
syndication I got a beard I got stuck
doing a bunch of authentication and
authorization and had to learn that and
it's actually it's it's quite fun to
work with so I thought I'd go around and
tell people how to do that and how it
works in a spread net core because it's
not that complicated but it is quite
important before we get started how many
of you are on asp.net core 2.0 today how
many of you have not are not on asp net
core at all today okay so for those of
you who are not on court core today a
lot of the stuff that I'm showing can be
done in all old MVC as well it's
different implementation wise you have
to write slightly different syntax but
it is possible to do kind of the same
things in a similar manner but a spec or
made it easier so
even if you're not in core you can take
away a lot of information from this
session
that's about all of these lights I had
I'm gonna be coding for the rest of the
session my goal is to do a very
practical walkthrough of how we do
authentication in F net core so I'm
gonna be showing you how we do all sent
ocation with local logins how we switch
over and start using social logins how
we combine several different social
logins how we do a sure ad b2c
authentication and how we use identity
server to do our authentication and I'm
gonna do that all in 55 minutes so it's
gonna be a fairly fast-paced before I
forget it though I just want to put up
one more slide I generally have it at
the end but I people are rushing out at
that time mostly all of the code that I
am writing is available on the internet
so you can just go and download it it
will have everything you need except for
my credentials for Twitter and Facebook
all of those credentials will be on my
screen during the session I would
suggest not using them for my sake and I
might reset them afterwards but you need
to make some minor changes to get to
work and if you you're interesting in
authentication and authorization and the
stuff that I'm talking about today but
you're not doing exactly what I'm
showing here there's a course on
Pluralsight that shows you exactly the
same thing 10 to 20 minute sessions on
specific implementations so if you want
to build your own authentication handler
there's a 20 minute module with that if
you want to do Facebook authentication
there's 20 minutes of that so you can go
in find the module that suits your needs
and you can look up that stuff for that
specific feature other than that let's
just go and switch over to my beautiful
application it is as you can see a
fantastic MVC application with bootstrap
so it looks like every other application
on the Internet
it's pretty simple it has a home page
which is this this SLO world that's it
it's got a login screen it's got a
register screen and it's got a secret
page which isn't very secret but if you
go to user info you can find out
information
about the currently login user and it
throws an exception because it's not
done that's kind of application I'll be
using for the entire day or entire
session so I'm going to add different
types of authentications to it and if we
walk over and we look at the code for it
look it's start up here actually start
up is completely uninteresting but
there's like we're using MVC and some
static files that's it I have in this
case I have an i user service I have a
little user service and let's look at
the implementation of the API for that
it's basically just has authenticate add
authenticate external add external we're
not going to look at the implementation
because it's ugly but it basically
stores the users in a JSON file on disk
do not ever ever do this but it's a demo
if we look at the controller stuff there
are some controls in here there's an
auth controller that has all of the
actions that we need so it's got login
and register and log outs which is the
stuff that we're going to be
implementing and it's got an endpoint
equal access denied and I want to point
that out because I'm not covering it in
any detail but in previous versions of
Microsoft authentication a user was
never put into a state of access denied
access denied and unauthorized or - or
unauthenticated or two different things
so used it used to be that when a user
went to a page that they didn't have
access to they were sent to the login
page you could never go and say I want
to send a user that is logged in but
doesn't have access to this specific
feature to a specific page they always
ended up on the login page there was no
difference between being logged in and
not having access and not being logged
in at all so they've added this feature
where you can say if you're logged in
but you don't have access we can handle
that separately from not being
authenticated at all which is actually
quite nice home controller is pretty
boring it has very little except for an
authorized attribute so I'm using
authorize attributes it's just the same
as we would do in any old a spinet MVC
application as well to make sure that
the user is authenticated and that is
about it
a couple of use in here obviously they
don't do a whole lot
so if we get started it and I want to
start out with doing local logins so
first of all before I do that how many
of you are doing local logins today you
have your own credential store on Prem
how many of you are terrified that you
have your local storage on Prem with
user credentials is one two three had
way less than all the people that said
that they had it and if I had it I would
be terrified but we still do it and I
still have stuff to do it so I thought
I'd start out in that end that we have
our own login our users or user
credentials in our application so the
first step to do is we go up to
configure services and we say services
dot add authentication that is step one
that adds the authentication services to
the dependency injection framework which
is the IOC container it doesn't add any
form of authentication this is just
foundational stuff that is used to
authenticate users it doesn't have any
actual authentication in there what we
get back from our authentication is an
authentication builder the
authentication builder is something that
we can then go and say I want to add
cookies so I want to have cookie
authentication in my application that's
it
that's that adds a cookie authentication
Handler that is responsible for making
sure that cookies work as an
authentication paradigm in your
application and then that uses the
foundational authentication services
from add authentication so in this case
we'll be using cookie and we need to
configure that a bit so I'm gonna add a
cookie configuration so it has a
callback delegate here and you get
options back and I'm just setting the
login path and the access denied path if
you leave these they all have default
values so I could literally just skip
that whole thing but you get some other
URLs that I didn't find work for me so I
went in and configured it like this
instead but it does have pretty good
defaults to begin with so it does have
things like cookie protection it turned
on and all of the standard defaults that
you'd want to have for your
authentication stuff so I'm putting in
cookies and then I need to tell my
authentication services what cook what
handler do I want to use to do it for my
indication so every handler that we add
to the authentication context has a name
if I don't specifically give my cookie
handler a name it gets a default name
and the default name is available under
a cookie authentication defaults cookie
authentication default thought
authentication scheme so if we look at
this it's just basically a string that
says cookies but all of the different
handlers so if I'm doing cook your
authentication there's a cookie
authentication defaults if I do open ID
connectors and open ID Connect defaults
so the defaults the standard is that
there is a static class that you can use
to get the default values for different
things for that specific handler so in
this case I'm just saying that I want to
use to cook your authentication handler
for everything so whenever a user comes
to my site look at the cookie
whenever I stell the use system to sign
the user in create a cookie whenever the
user is considered not having access
redirect the user using the cookie
authentication handler which will
redirect to both access denied if the
user needs to login and I challenge the
user to login tell that cookie
authentication handler that it should do
whatever it does to get the person
logged in so I'm defaulting to that for
everything which is basically everything
we need and that is yeah literally
everything I need from a service point
of view
was I complicated no it wasn't
complicated good if that is complicated
it will get way more complicated
throughout the session and then one of
the things like I generally forget for
some reason is you need to go down to
your configure method I need to do app
use authentication if you don't do that
everything works fine except the user
never gets logged in which is
potentially not fine but it kind of
there's no exceptions being thrown it
just your application looks like
everything works and then the user is
not logged in don't forget that part
because that is the middleware that will
actually make sure that once the request
passes this middle where the user is
authenticated there is a user setup in
the system there's a current user
context that you can work with
and that means that when we get to MVC
the users authenticated so when we have
the authorized attribute that works once
I got my services in place in my
middleware I need to go over to my oath
controller and here in my oath
controller I'm gonna need to do a few
things first of all I need to register a
user I don't have any users in the
system so step one is to register one we
look at the first action here it
basically just returns a view so it
returns the form to sign in or sorry to
register and if we look at the second
register action here it's an HTTP POST
and the post here all it does so far it
checks to make sure that the the model
state is valid basically that I have
filled out all the fields that I need
validation is sparse in this application
and by sparse I mean
crap but I trusted people using my app
to fill in everything and then I used my
user service and I say if everything is
filled in I'm just gonna add a new user
with that name that email address and
that password and that gives me user
back from my user store and this is
where I need to go and do my
authentication stuff so I'm gonna remove
that and I'm gonna say register you
through one so the first thing I need to
do is I need to create a list of claims
so claims is the default way of doing
authentication in asp.net and has been
so for the last few years before that we
had a identity and I whatever claims
principle or I principle it's all claims
now so I'm gonna go ahead and create a
claims list so I'm saying that I've got
a name identifier I got a name and I got
an email and these are the values for it
once I got that I'll go and take my
claims and I'll use those to create a
new identity so I'm creating a new
claims identity passing in the claims
and I pass in the name of the
authentication scheme that was used for
this user to sign in so in this case
cook your authentication then I take my
identity and I pass it in and create a
principle and once I've got my principle
I can pretty easily that's an extension
method so we need to have that I'll just
await HTTP context I'll sign in a sink
and give that my principal and after
that I redirect the user to user
information about user information
action on the home controller that is
pretty much everything I do so signing I
think you doesn't actually do a whole
lot but on the way out as the request
goes past on the way out this system
will basically set the cookie and make
sure that the cookie is protected and
encrypted and signed and all of that
stuff and whenever the user comes back
after having been redirected to user
information asked the user comes in that
request will have that cookie the cookie
authentication or the authentication
middleware would use will use two
authentication services to go and say
can you please authenticate this user it
looks at the cookie rehydrates the
cookie and resets the user context and
the user should be logged in and I'm
saying should but let's say and see if
it actually does
let's go register there this and I'm
gonna register user I'm gonna written to
me so we'll do that I'm registered I'm
logged in I have a user and you can see
here it says that my user name is Chris
fine it says that their I have three
claims they're all issued by local
authority so it's issued by me I could
give it a different issue if I wanted to
here is the claim type which is
humongously long but and makes the
cookie big but you can make them shorter
and custom if you want the name and
email address
what's that semi understandable cool
next step right now I can sign out
I can't log out user so logging out the
user is actually as simple if not
simpler so if we close this down and we
look at the logout endpoint one little
detail here by the way I have an HD post
so my logout button actually posts a
form the reason for this is that I've
learned that certain browsers chrome
will in some cases prefetch pages for
you to make your browsing faster
we'll actually go and prefetch stuff for
you in certain scenarios if your logout
endpoint is a HTTP GET it will go and
potentially prefetch the logout
endpoints logging their user out of your
system so when the user clicks something
he or she will be redirected to that
page and then logged out and have to log
in again go to that page after login
gets logged out again because chrome is
nice enough so every time you click
something you have to re log in not a
great solution I've not seen this happen
a lot of times it happens once in a
while so I'm just for safety I'm doing
HTTP POST and what do we need to do in
here well we just need to do sign out
user by the way never ever take on a
project where you don't have pre-built
snippets takes way too long
just having pre-built snippets for
everything makes life a lot easier so
what you do is you just say await HTTP
context of sign out async and redirect
to action index home once again
this thing is async it's probably going
to be very fast but it's it sets up some
stuff into authentication services so
that when the request goes out the
cookie is being removed because of the
cook you handler so this doesn't
actually tie into the cookie handler at
all the feature I'm doing here like sign
out is saying ties into the
authentication services the
authentication service then looks that
they configured handler for signing out
and finds that I configure that to be
the cookie authentication handler and
then it uses to cook your sent occation
handler to sign out so I'm in no way
tied in to anything specific and I can
switch things around using that I can go
back out here I can press logout
and it looks at okay fairly simple right
yes Chris that is awesomely simple I
know
last step logging in so I got register I
need to get my log in working as well
because I've got a user now so we look
at the log in one I've got the first
action which is to get which gives me
the form the second action is my post
and yes I do things like validate ante
forgery token for example to make sure
that we can't do replace and stuff like
that and in the post
I check my modal state if it's valid if
it's not I just returned the view then I
look at my user service and says can you
place all tentacle this user who use the
email address here's the password if I
don't get a user back from my user
service I add a model state error and
then I return the view again with an
error and finally I need to login the
user and by the way yes this is the way
it should be you should not be throwing
exceptions if the user is not available
anything like that do return null
exceptions are slow and it's not an
exceptional state that people fill in
the wrong password so what I'm going to
do actually I'm gonna I'm gonna hold off
on that what I need to do it's actually
gonna be very very similar to what I'm
doing here because I've got a user right
and this code here signs in the user so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take this
I'm gonna do that extract method sign in
user I have issues I know that so I'm
gonna have to move this to the end of my
code because I suffer from C do which is
OCD with the letters in the right order
then you go up here and we just do
return oh wait sign-in user user like
that there's no difference between
registering a user or signing any user
I'm doing the same thing I go to user I
need to set the claims once I set the
claims I need to sign in to use to using
date should be context and then I'm good
to go having that in place I should be
able to hopefully that is not me that is
me
fantastically complicated password
and it works good login so if we look at
just quickly have a recap of the code we
start up and start up with we start out
in start up we add our authentication
service we configured it the handlers
that we need and we add the middleware
and then in the actual controller we
just depend on the HP context sign-in I
think an HTP context sign out I think
that's what we need to do and they are
pretty self-explanatory sign in async
takes and prints a principal ok I need
to create a principal to create a
principal I need an identity to create
an identity I need some claims so you
can sort of backtrack and figure out
what to do but I figured out that all of
my clients basically now want to have
other kinds of sign-in they want to do
social logins everybody wants to login
with Facebook or Twitter or something
like that
actually talking about that how many of
you do if there's a login form on a
registration form on their website do
how many of you use Facebook or any
social provider if that is available
instead of doing a local login how many
of you will do a local login how am i
keeping hands up keep your hands up you
have enough strength to keep your hands
up how many of you have a unique
password for every website you ever go
to or a few hunts coming down I must
admit I do social logins whenever I can
because I true hyrum their entire
sentence before you judge me because I'm
gonna say I trust Facebook to keep my
credential safe
I actually I trust Facebook in every
single way I will know that they will
sell me out as soon as anybody will pay
for it but I'm also pretty sure they
will keep my credential safe and also
because they have my credentials doesn't
mean that they get to see everything and
can log into every single application
all of that they issue a token and that
token is used by the third party
application it doesn't necessarily give
Facebook access to that application and
it doesn't necessarily give that
application access to your Facebook so
I'm happy with that and I see a lot of
clients going towards social logins
because it's it's simple so what we want
to do is we want to go back to the sort
of class I want to add another form of
authentication in here
and I don't think I can do this easily
so let's see if we can do it like this
that's the one so I'm just gonna go in
here and I'm gonna say I want to add
some other stuff so besides cookie
authentication I want to add facebook i
want to add twitter and as I said
preview credentials these are the ones
that you will have to switch out in your
if you download the code
these are credentials they are supposed
to be kept safe and should not be shown
to other people on a huge screen in
front of 200 people at a conference
I will reset this after the conference
you can't do anything with them I've
said that for the last five conferences
they are still the same but you can't
actually do anything with them because
the app on Facebook white lists the URL
lists that you can use and it's
hard-coded to only allow localhost so in
theory you can use this and just but you
can only do local development with my
account so it doesn't really matter but
please don't get your own one it's
simple so I add this in here and add
Facebook and Twitter and after that
that's kind of it so I need then I'm
gonna go to my view for register
actually I'm not I'm gonna go to my
that's not the one I want to go here I
wonder if my login screen sorry to begin
with and down here after my login form
I'm gonna go and say nope nope that's
the one external provider is test one so
first thing I do in here is I inject a
service called
I authenticate scheme provider that is
part of add authentication it gives me
access to all of these authentication
schemes that are available in this case
cookie Facebook and Twitter cuz those
are the ones that I have registered and
then down here I go and say for each
scheme in get request handler schemes I
think that method will give me back all
the handlers that does redirects so if I
put in it won't give me cookie because
cookie is local it will only give me
ones that will redirect to other
services for sign-in so in this case it
will give me Twitter and Facebook back
and then I create a link here and say
action is login external path
long the name of this game as an ID
parameter and the name of the button or
the display of the text on the button is
supposed to be this display name of that
scheme so basically render one for H
that's fine
login external is not available at the
moment so if we go back to Earth
controller we look at login sort of here
I add another endpoint login external it
takes the ID which is going to be the
name of the scheme that I want to use so
Facebook or Twitter and then I go HTTP
context or challenge async and I give it
to ID so I'm basically this time I'm
telling it that I want you to challenge
the user using Facebook or Twitter it
depending on what I've tossed in and
then I give it what is called
authentication properly saying that once
the users been logged in redirect to
user info if you do not do this
it defaults to redirecting back to the
same URL or the same action which means
that the user after having gone to
Facebook and logged in or Twitter the
user gets redirected back to this
endpoint which then goes sweet you want
to sign in with Facebook I'm going to
redirect you to Facebook Facebook goes
and says you've already signed in you're
fine I'm issuing a token to your system
you come back to this system here your
system redirects to this end point you
get redirected to Facebook and you kind
of get the whole thing that it's gonna
suck it you get like 20 redirects and
then chrome explosion your face and says
that you were [ __ ] ain't not quite
those terms but but kind of so I've got
that going all I need to do now is log
up my user look out my user and we press
login we press look at that Facebook
Twitter go to Facebook you need an
internet connection to connect to social
providers connect it's actually kind of
cool because you get to see that it's
creating this massive URL at the top and
you don't have to care it sorts
everything out for you so all I need to
do is get connected to the Wi-Fi those
of you who are now
torrenting stuff of why well internet
can play stop there is connected open go
enter enter I end up at Facebook
I end up with Facebook there it is
it says that auth demo which is my
Facebook app wants to have access to my
public profile and my illa email address
and since I do trust the creator of this
application to be an awesome guy I'm
gonna say yes
so continuous Chris Facebook issues a
token sends that back to the system it
sends it back to a custom URL that you
don't see but it basically has a
different URL where it caches that and
put that token uses that token to
authenticate the user it creates a user
identity or a claims principle and signs
in the user and as you can see here it
has let's see if I can do this I get
Facebook issued claims that says here's
the name identifier which is the unique
ID of me on Twitter or sorry on Facebook
my email address my name my given name
my surname because those are the claims
that Facebook will issue for me if I do
the same thing with with Twitter I'm
gonna get different claims which is kind
of annoying because we do end up with
depending on what I logged in with
actually I can show you that if we log
out here I could do login if I log in
with Twitter instead so depending on
what provider I use I'm gonna get
different claims so I got get here I
sign-in always prep your machine with
your passwords screw that okay so I'm
not showing you Twitter and we're gonna
use Facebook if I were to do Twitter
you'd get different claims just trust me
on that one which is kind of annoying
because I would continuously my
application have to go if the user has
claimed a I can do this if the user has
claimed B I can do this I would have to
do that all the time what we often end
up doing is saying I won't have a
standardized set of claims and
potentially I want to collect other
information than what I get from my
provider so I'm it's very likely that I
will be collecting information that my
provider will never give to me so to get
that extra information or correct the
information that you get from your
provider there's a there's a pattern for
that and if we go back here
we go back to the startup class what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go down here to
the bottom and I'm gonna add another
handler in here I'm gonna say add cookie
again but I'm gonna name this handler
temp cookie so this is a customer ID
it's the same handler it's the same code
as this thing here but instead of having
this name it now has this name and then
I go into my Twitter one and I say
options dot sign-in scheme and set that
to tame temp cookie I'll do the same
thing to Facebook because Facebook and
Twitter will only authenticate user it
will not sign in the user on its own so
what happens once Facebook the Facebook
and sorry that was it needs to go there
they will only authenticate the user and
then they will go and say once I have
authenticated
please use this scheme here to sign in
the user
it defaults to cookie so that's fine but
in this case I'm actually telling it
that once you've authenticated the user
using Facebook or Twitter I want you to
sign in using this thing called temp
cookie temp cookie doesn't actually sign
in the user at all in the system it
creates a cookie with an authentication
authenticated user but it doesn't sign
the user in because the system expects
the user to be signed in using that
handler so it's gonna be sort of semi
signed in using a different cookie and
not really signed into the system but
there is still a user for me to access
does that make sense
ish well see when I start using it I
think it makes more sense so what we're
gonna do here so I'm gonna make little
change in my worth controller in my
challenge external well change this and
say once you've registered or signed in
on Facebook or Twitter can you please go
to auth slash register external instead
like that and if we go down and we'll do
that here in register external what I'll
do is I'll go ahead and I'll take a look
at the HP context and say can you please
authenticate this user specifically
using temp cookie
so normally the user will not be signed
in here but there will still be a
temporary cookie for me with the user in
it and then I say if I didn't get a user
back basically the user hasn't been
temporarily signed in then
hey just redirect the person to home
because I don't want to I don't want to
mess with that then afterwards I take I
take to pray the principal basically the
user currently user and I get the name
identifier my unique ID from that
provider and I ask the authenticate
external thing saying can you please go
and see if there's anyone in the system
with this unique ID if there isn't one
of those in the earth if there isn't one
of those in the system so basically the
user has never been here before
it goes and says oh sorry if there is
one of those and the users been here
before please sign in the user using
this user otherwise please go ahead and
show a view where the user can fill out
their name and email this means that if
I come back from Facebook oh and I
haven't been to the site before so I'm a
new user I'm basically registering
myself it will go and show me a name in
the email field that I can fill out and
it will pre-populate the name and email
fields with the value that is available
in the current identity so for Facebook
it means that the values will be
pre-populated because I do get them from
Twitter which I obviously can't show you
I will not get the email address so I
will only get a name and then the user
has to fill those out and they can
change them and correct them as they
want and then once they've filled out
that form and they're coming they're
coming back and reposted out stuff we'll
do sign in external know what I read
sorry
register external post is what I want I
got an action here where you post back
your credit your information your user
name and your email address once again I
go and ask the system can you please
authenticate the user using the
temporary cookie not the real one
if there is no signed in temporary user
then hey go back to home I don't really
care if the model state isn't valid
which basically in this case means if
they haven't filled out the fields show
them the form again if everything is
filled out I
my user service that can you please
register a new user in the system here
there's a claim called name identifier
for this user unique ID for that
provider can you please use that unique
ID as the ID of the user and here is the
user's name and email and it adds the
user to the database with that name that
email and that unique identifier I'm
somewhat naive here because I'm just
assuming that the unique identifier the
name identifier is going to be different
for all providers in the entire world
for this user they are not because
Facebook is gonna have one and Twitter's
gonna have one absolutely but it's very
possible that I were to build an
application that you could use for
authentication that happen to give that
identifier to a different user which
then becomes scary because it means that
you will have two users being able to
log in to your system from two different
systems and they're two different people
but they end up being the same in the
system so you probably want to have a
little field here that says Facebook so
if the user is logged in with Facebook
here's the Facebook ID if it's they've
logged in with Twitter here's a new
Twitter ID if they've logged in with
Gmail leaves the Gmail ID and all of
that and finally I embody I call sign in
external sign in external is actually
quite simple it has two two rows of code
it first it starts out by saying can you
please sign out the user from the temp
cookie that will remove the temporary
cookie and user is now not signed in at
all and then it goes and says can you
please sign in the user and it just
reuses the old sign in method to
actually sign in the user using the
proper cookie the real one and after
that the user is signed into the system
so if we save this we go back here we do
login actually it's nicer to do it in
register so what I'll do is I'm just
gonna go down here so register will do
we'll just do that I'm just drawing
these out the handlers on the register
page as well so if we go to register
with registration stuff Facebook Twitter
I go Facebook I get sent over to
Facebook Facebook dan says I already
know who you are cuz you're already
signed in so I get single sign on
because I've already approved this
application for authentication there is
don't ask why and I end up at this page
here and here I can collect all these I
can get them to correct their
information I can get them to add
information that's not there and you can
get them to put in their address or
whatever you need and right now if I
were to go to the home page or the user
information page it would treat me as
not signed in because I'm signed in
using that temporary cookie if I go and
press register here it then goes and
registers may using the information in
temporary cookie adds me to the local
system and it adds these claims here and
I get my default claims the ones that I
want and if I log out and I go log in
again and I log in using Facebook you'll
see that it now corrects the claims for
me so I don't get the Facebook claims
anymore I get my custom claims instead
so I get this standardized set of claims
from application ok does that make sense
how many of you are in love with social
authentication and will use that for the
rest of your life and that's gonna save
the world a few I like you guys for the
rest of you how many of you are using
Azure Active Directory today to do
authentication how many of you love
Active Directory it's one two hands okay
I thought I was gonna show you Active
Directory but I thought I make it make a
little twist on it so I'm gonna use a
sure ad b2c so Azure ad b2c is ash your
Active Directory business-to-consumer
which basically means it's an accurate
assure Active Directory but then it's
actually not natural Active Directory
it's kind of an Active Directory behind
the scenes but it's not being treated
like one so you can't use it quite as
you would with an Active Directory but
it adds features like social logins so
what you get is you get an Active
Directory and you get endpoints
that are open ID connect specific and
they allow you to configure your service
and say I want users to be able to log
in with local logins I want to have
users logging in using Facebook and
Twitter
and I want them to be able to be
registered there a user account I want
them to be able to edit their user
account and they take care of all of
that all you need to do is add
integration with that service and then
they take care of logging in users
verifying email addresses connect
collecting extra information all the
stuff that I did manually in my previous
version so I have an ad b2c set up in
the cloud and it's configured and done
and I'm actually not going to show you
that if you want to see more of that
that Pluralsight course will we'll walk
you through setting it up as well but
I'm more interested in the client side
the a spirit core stuff so once again I
have an identical application and if we
look at that it's a little bit different
we'll see that in the the auth
controller but once again I'll go back
to startup because this is where one
starts and we're going to service this
first thing services dot authentication
step one step two add open add open ID
connect so a sure ad b2c supports open
ID Connect which is a standard interface
for authenticating users and I need to
give it a name for my handler in this
case I am weirdly enough gonna name it
b2c underscore b2c underscore one
underscore sign underscore in and it
needs to be configured there is a thing
with Azure ad b2c
it's the fact that it's not a hundred
percent open ID Connect compliant
because Open ID Connect builds on the
idea that you can authenticate users and
that's all you can do Microsoft wants to
add other features to it like editing
profile information and registering
users and signing up you signing up and
signing out and signing in and all that
so what they've done is they've said
we're gonna have what we call profiles
so a profile is an action that I can do
so you can have a sign-in profile a sign
out profile sign in or up
profile a edit account profile and those
profiles basically define define what
the user can do but you need to treat
them as different end points and
different handlers in your clients which
is kind of a pain so the reason that I'm
naming this thing here b2c underscore
one underscore sign underscore in is
because my profile in the cloud is
called b2c underscore one underscore
sign underscore in for the sign in
profile Chris why the hell would you
name it like that
I didn't b2c underscore on one
underscore is prepended by Microsoft for
you why I have no idea but it's there so
you have to use it so what I'm doing is
I'm naming my handler the same thing is
my profile and then I need to configure
my options but I'm gonna have several
profiles so to be able to support that
I'm actually gonna go ahead and say ad
b2c con options config that's the one so
I'm creating this helper method here and
all it does it basically it takes the
options parameter the configuration and
the policy that I want to use then it
creates the metadata address and says
you can find the metadata for this
endpoint at this location here with the
policy appended at the end then I tell
it that here's my client ID which you
get from the cloud I want to get an ID
token I want the user to be signed I
signed out or redirected sorry to slash
after compare signing out when the user
comes back from Asher and having been
authenticated please redirect the user
to this endpoint here and when they sign
out please redirect to this your
endpoint here these are endpoints that
you don't touch though these are handled
by the authentication system but they
need to be there they need to have
specific URLs and it and callback paths
have to be unique per policy so that's
why I'm basically saying sign in - oh I
DC - policy name and also the name claim
that comes back from Asher has the
different standards I have to say that
the user's name claim comes back with a
claim type name not this
HTTP colon slash la blah which is that
long so I need to configure that once I
got those configuration properties in
place I can go and say configure OpenID
Connect options and I can pass in my
options and my policy which is going to
be that so I got my sign-in policy up
and running there are then two other
policies that I want to have so I'm
gonna go ahead and say which is the
wonder one sorry ad b2c
that's the one sorry so I create two
other policies one for sign in or up
which is basically a sign in form with a
button that says register and then I
create one for sign up which is just for
registration make sense yes okay once
I'm done with that I go and add cookie
all of these providers will authenticate
the users they will not sign the user
into the system you need cookie
authentication to actually keep a
persistent sign in for that user
so I add cookie at the end the
authentication configuration here is a
little bit more complicated it's going
to be able to see both defaults so in
this case instead of just passing in
like I did before cookie authentication
defaults dot authentication scheme I'm
splitting out the different options
saying that when the user wants to when
you sign in the user basically once
they've been authenticated and they cook
your authentic or I need to sign in the
user used to cook your authentication
when you want to sign out unless you
specifically tell the system what
provider to sign out from sign out from
the cookie authentication if the user is
going to a page where they don't have
access and they need to be automatically
challenged to sign in please sign them
in and use the the handler called b2c
unscrew one underscore sign underscore
in underscore our unscrew up you don't
want to have that in a meeting you want
to have shorter stuff and finally a
default authentication scheme means that
when the user arrives at the application
when the request comes in from his
browser Play
use this provider the cookie
authentication one to verify that user
is signed in so we can configure all
these in different ways and have
different providers or handlers or
schemes for different things in this
case the only one I really want to
change is the default challenge one and
all that once is going to be cookie
authentication and finally before I
forget it
app dot use authentication to make sure
that the user actually gets
authenticated the services that you
register up here doesn't actually have
access to anything in the system it will
never know when to run properly unless
you add this thing here that make sure
that everything works so how do we do
this if we look at the controllers well
first of all my auth controller is way
simpler in this case there's only login
logout and register because I don't have
any forms anymore Microsoft handles all
of that for me this is all I need so
let's look at log in so signing in a
user here is gonna be ad b2c challenge
last one and what I need here if I say
please challenge the user and I want to
challenge the user using b2c underscore
one b2c underscore one underscore sign
underscore in like that and after the
redirect please redirect or design in
place a redirect user to user info same
thing as before the only difference is
that I in this case have to specifically
tell it what scheme that I want to use
to sign in the user we go to to register
I do exactly the same thing I send a
challenge but instead of sending them to
sign in I send them to sign up and
finally signing out a user is actually
quite simple first of all we do the
await HCP context don't sign out a thing
like that that will sign you out from
the default sign in sign out scheme
which is cookie authentication and then
nope that's not the one I want I want to
have sorry ad b2c sign that's the one I
want so here comes a little kicker I
need to sign out the user using the same
scheme that the user signed in with and
there's a cool and that's actually the
reason that I named my schemes or my
handlers here the same thing as my
profiles in Azure because when Asscher
issues the cookie or issues the
authentication they will include a claim
that is called TFP the TFP claim will
contain the name of the profile that was
used when signing in this user so by
when the user signs out I go and look at
the TFP claim to find out what was the
name of the profile the user used when
signing in and then I sell the system
can you please sign out the user with
that same with a scheme with the same
name as that profile does that make
sense so if the user signs in using b2c
underscore one underscore sign on the
screen they will sign out using that
same thing so if we try this out you'll
see how it works we'll go register
because I don't have a user there's a
reason I don't do a sure demos anymore I
hate internet so I've got different
things here
I've got email sign up we've got
Facebook we've got Twitter because all
of this is configured I'm not going to
Twitter but I've configured this in
Asscher so they have all the information
if I go email signup I might regret this
but let's try it I'm gonna say Chris at
59 NORTHCOM that's my address no I'm
apparently not I'm gonna say Chris
that's the one send verification code I
press that I press that it goes away
scary thing here is if you're on stage
and you start typing in your password
field after you click that button when
the verification code thing pops up it
actually takes focus you start typing
your password in that field in clear
text it is brilliant I might have done
that a few times so we'll do password
exclamation mark and Microsoft is nice
enough to verify my email address so I
need to pull up my phone I need to
my email client and I need to refresh my
emails
Microsoft on behalf of both demo your
code is zero one nine three four six
verify code nope I don't want to say
that and display name is gonna be zero
call creates so Microsoft handles all of
that for me they will do the
verification the whole thing that I put
my display name you can ask it to
collect any information that you want
and they will make sure to add fields
for them to input that and they will
make sure it's populating all of that so
they will give you all of the UI that
you need and then I get logged in like
this and you can see it issues it using
this issue it is really hard to do that
backwards this issue are here which is
my end point my usher ad b2c and I get
the claims name identifier I get an
object identifier which is the users
object ID in the in da D my email I get
a claim that says new user so that claim
is issued when they use of registers so
I can treat them differently I get my
name and as you can see I get a TFP
claim saying the user signed in using
b2c honest with one underscore sign on
this crop so when I sign out now it's
going to look at that TFP claim it's
gonna figure out which handler to use
you didn't see it but I was actually
sent over to a charade a to sign out
there as well so I do get signed out
disabling single sign-on if you don't
want to have that you want to keep
single sign-on you can sign out the user
locally and as soon as they click login
they will be redirected and
automatically signed it back in again
which is not what most clients want okay
you've seen ASHRAE db2 say I'm a fan but
there are other options one option - I
very often put in is identity server so
identity server is a tool built by brock
allen and dominic buyer and it's kind of
cool because you get an authentication
provider an identity provider out of the
box it said you just get it off
nougat you install it in your
application it doesn't have a UI by
default so if we go over here and we
look at the the code for it by default
you go in and you
configure your identity server here to
have like these are the different things
I want to configure it with here is a
test user here is some identity
resources so all of the configuration
that I need is being done in the
services here and then you just add it
to your request pipeline by calling app
to use identity server that will give
you an open ID connect endpoint to
authenticate users with it will not give
you UI so to get a UI which is what I've
got here you need to go to github and
download it and it will give you an MVC
application with the views so you can go
in and customize all of the UI of it and
how it works and everything so it's not
an external identity provider that you
control completely if you want to
integrate with that which is what I want
to do I create another web here so we'll
go set that I startup go control f5 I'll
go and I'll do the same thing as I've
done before we start up and start up
we'll do services dot ad authentication
we'll go ahead and do add open ID
connect because that's what we're going
to use for identity server and then
cookie for the open ID connect stuff we
won't have some configuration so I'm
going to put in some config here telling
it this is where you'll find the
identity server we are identity provider
localhost port 5000 I'm doing it on HTTP
not HTTP if you ever ever ever do that I
will hunt you down I will find you while
you sleep and terrorize you like Freddy
Krueger it should always you don't want
to send credentials over HTTP so you
need htps ID specifically have to go in
and configure it to say I don't require
HTTPS I don't have HCBS because I'm
doing this demo locally and it causes
some issues for me moving it around but
for everything else leave that thing and
use SSL if you don't want to pay for it
let's encrypt is free start doing SSL on
everything I give you a client ID so the
client that that's configured an
identity server I tell it where to
redirect after the user is signed out I
have this thing here which is a bit of a
weird one say
tokens means that when the user comes
back after having been authenticated
please save the original token together
with this user in a cookie and have that
for future use if you don't do that
identity server when you sign out
identity server won't actually redirect
you back to your application again it
will just stop there because it doesn't
know who you are so the token that you
get when you sign in needs to be passed
to identity server as a hint token hint
when you sign out otherwise signing out
and automatically redirecting back to
your application doesn't work so this
thing is to be set to true and finally I
have an event thing here and I listen to
on remote failure so if something goes
wrong while logging in do this basically
redirect user / own remote failure is
the same thing as the user presses
cancel when signing in I don't find that
to be a remote failure but it's
considered that so if you don't add this
if the user goes and says I want to log
in and then presses cancel your
application dies so you need this thing
we've got my cookie in there I've got my
I identify or my open ID connect so what
I need up here is ideas or defaults do
pretty much the same thing I did before
set it up to use cookie for everything
but default challenge so if I go to a
web page and it needs to challenge user
automatically used to open ID Connect
one as you can see your open I reconnect
defaults just as with cookie
authentication defaults and finally we
need to go back in here and we need to
say app dot use authentication to
actually enable authentication in our
system once we've got that we that's
kind of same as I've done three times
before and if we go over to Earth
controller we'll see that I've got the
same as without your ID basically I've
got the login and logout I don't have
register because register is not
supported there's no way to do
registration out of the box without
empty server it will authenticate user
it will not register users so I don't
need a register endpoint which is kinda
nice on the other hand users can
register to my system which is kind of
crap and in here we'll do idea challenge
why the ID DS challenge that's one I
want so challenging is the same as
before I just send back a child when
they want to log in challenge San Juan
it defaults since the challenge default
scheme is open and you connect it will
use that and for signing out I will just
do oh yes that's one same as I did with
Usher ad b2c first I sign out my local
cookie using a shippi context of sign
out async and then I sign out using the
open ID connect one and that will
redirect me to the identity server to
get a proper sign out there otherwise
you'll have signed a single sign on
again with that in place control that
five got five minutes I got one more
demo to go application boots up I press
login you'll see up here in the address
bar it redirects me to it redirects me
to port 5000 which is my identity server
I get this identity server for UI which
is a default one as I said fully styler
ball user name your call password test
login I get redirected back and I have
this user signed in I have this
configured here to issue my stuff as my
identity server which is not a great
name and you get a bunch of claims
claims it's up to you so you define what
claims the identity server should issue
for you you have full control over
everything because it's your identity
server one thing left here as I want to
demo is there's a spine here and by spa
I mean there's a JavaScript in here I
think that's what you call a spa right
it's a web page with a javascript in it
it is called equals an API and I call
the API and I get ID one back that's
fine because my API is in the same
application on the same port on the same
host it means that it automatically or
that authenticates the request using a
cookie because it will send the
authentication cookie to the API problem
with authenticating using cookies with
API is that we can get cross-site
request forgeries that we causes
problems
so what we want to do is we don't when
we're doing API is we want to make sure
we don't use cookie authentication if
they're on the same domain so instead we
want to use tokens JSON web token bearer
tokens and to do that we can go back to
our startup class we'll add another one
of these we'll do add JWT bearer like
that actually I'm gonna cheat so we're
gonna do to make this faster ah that's
the one that's the one
and I want IDs J that's one so I'm
adding another handler here saying add
jason web token bearer handler
once again I tell it to not use HTTPS
don't ever do that and then I tell it
you have to be have access to API one to
be able to access this thing so I have
another handler that will make sure that
if that is requested it will verify an
access token that is being sent through
a header instead of the cookie if I go
and test this now it's still gonna work
because I still out sent gating using
the cookie because my API if we look up
here has an authorized attributes that
just says make sure the user is
authorized I don't care how just make
sure it's your authorized if we change
that and we changed it to authentication
schemes and we say JDT defaults dot
authentication scheme I'm now telling
the API that only authenticated users
authorized user sorry authenticated
using the bearer token if I take this I
go back out here and I press call API it
freezes for a while and then it gets 401
unauthorized that's kind of sweet I get
it for a one I've secured my API but I
can't actually call my API kind of sucks
so what we can do then is I can go to
home spa I'm just gonna quickly do this
there's more to learn about this but
what I'm doing is I'm gonna add a
sign-in button and a sign out button and
in my API here man is some functionality
to sign in so basically when the user
opens the page I use a client library
called oh I DC client
jas which is written by Brock Allen
which is an open ID client for
JavaScript using that I can say please
go when the page loads please go and get
a user and it's going to look for a user
in local session storage if there's not
no such user it doesn't do anything but
when I call sign in click the sign-in
button it uses the OID C client to
basically sign in to use using a pop-up
sign out sign up use using a pop-up and
whenever I do an HTTP call in this case
I'll do fetch
I add a header here called authorization
with bearer and the users access token
so I'm using access tokens instead of my
cookie and if i refresh this page you
will now see I get a few buttons if I
call the API not know access because it
doesn't do cookies
if I press sign in it's gonna pop up a
window I get automatic signed in because
I'm already signed in at the identity
server you don't even need the pop-up
you can actually do it silently so the
user doesn't see that you're doing a
sign-in as long as they're signed in on
that enter provider if I call the API it
goes ID 1 because it's now sending an
access token in an orthros ation header
and we got a token authentication and
even if I log out I come back here I
look at my spa page I'm still signed in
because there's a cooked access token in
my session storage that it uses to
authenticate user and if I call the API
even though I don't have the cookie I
can still use this thing here so we can
mix and match or authentication as well
having that said moving your API to a
different domain name or a subdomain is
better for security reasons but if
you're gonna mix put them in the same
make sure that you have web token
authentication on the API and cook your
authentication on your applique or web
application code is available there if
you have any questions I will be around
if you have more want more information
you want to see how to configure
identity server there are courses on
that specifically on that course of
course there's information on doing
exactly this demo from start with all of
the configuration as well other than
that thank you so much for listening and
I hope you have a good day
oh if you liked the session please fill
out an eval or drop a green note if you
didn't like the session come up to me
talk to me I'll explain why it was
awesome and then you'll drop a green
note on the way out right
[Applause]